good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Monday hope everyone's
having a fabulous day fabulous fabulous
and speaking of fabulous it's the most
glamorous show-stopping girl I know my
co-host who was holding it down here in
the states for me this last week hey Jax
how you doing darn good thank you
speaking of fabulous it's turdy sister
because
turdy and her other sister there are so
many it's so confusing we're so fabulous
this weekend we are all dying to hear
about your weekend in Lisbon
by the way so it's worth mentioning I
could not this weekend pronounce Lisbon
because because same for me because
Jackie and I you know as a part of our
business we use a lot of different
platforms to upload podcastings one of
the platforms we use and we actually
recently started using them is called
libsin and when we first started using
this platform we couldn't say it because
it's obviously Lisbon but now we're so
custom
that when I got to Lisbon I could not
say it correctly it was a culture shock
for a podcaster it was a culture shock
for a podcaster
so pardon while I you know I kept just
saying Portugal because I could not say
Elizabeth of course
how was Portugal I went to Portugal on
Wednesday I for those who don't know my
friend Brian who's been on the show many
times it was his 40th birthday and he
was selling like celebrating like this
big milestone honestly I didn't know how
big he was going until we got there is
that because he didn't tell anyone or
just because you just assumed it was
going to be something and then it was
something else
he did say he's like I'm going all out
I'm going all out but it went above and
beyond what I could have imagined it was
it was basically it was four days three
nights and every night was a wedding
like it was insane the first thing was
like a big welcome reception this big
dinner he took over this beautiful
restaurant that was like a palace
and then the second night was he rented
out this castle and it was it was
literally a wedding it was a dance floor
a stage had performances the third night
he took over this club where we did like
a roast and then it was just like this
Rave it was so
beyond my expectations it was amazing
and I have to say my expectations I've
never been to Lisbon and it really
wasn't a place I ever planned on going
um so my expectations were low for like
the city itself it was amazing first of
all like Lisbon itself is so cute it's
like so quintessential you're up the
cobblestone streets the cute little
shops like it was really beautiful like
this these Hills these the hills I could
have oh my God I could have died uh but
it was so beautiful
um so I was already like overcome with
you on it it's true sounds like you
picked up a little something something
no no no I'm fine
um I was already like you know my
expectations were
hi no what's the word like beat
oh exceeded exceeded before anything
even started because I was really so
blown away with how cute Lisbon is like
people don't talk about it now I
understand Brian is like a he has a Visa
he's becoming a permanent resident there
like I totally get it it's so cute
that's so awesome tell me about the
roast who was the best okay
unlisted him so he had a one of the
nights like it was a rose which is such
a good idea such a good idea yes I told
you like nothing was off limits really
he said you could say anything you want
tell any story but just don't talk about
Dean his son
I'm like you don't have to tell us that
like we're not gonna we're not talking
about your son yeah so the third night
he took over this um it's a it was a gay
club but they had this really great
stage for drag queens so we use that
stage for the roast Brian sat up on
stage I hosted the roast I roasted Brian
and then he had five people roast it was
his best friend from high school his
college roommate Taylor strecker John me
and then at the 11th Hour like the night
before Brian's former business manager
Adam was like can I please roast Brian
I'm like it's not up to me it's up to
Brian so Brian was like yeah of course
and they worked together he just retired
but they I think they worked together
for 15 years and Adam has been waiting
for this day his entire life he his was
so long everyone got five minutes he
must have been up there for 15 minutes
but he said everything that he needed to
say he went so hard he went so deep it
was he was Far and Away the best like
and he was so unexpected too like he
wasn't even supposed to do it that's so
funny it was hysterical it was actually
a great idea for a birthday you have to
be really strong like I could never yeah
no I could never you could never but he
must have been really good for you to
admit that he was the best and better
than you oh he was better than me yeah
yeah I know he was amazing amazing and
then the night before that was like the
main event which was Brian took over
this castle that was so beautiful on the
beach it was like a 30 40 minute drive
you pull up it literally it was Game of
Thrones like it was this it was King's
Landing it was this huge castle he took
over the whole thing and
it was this beautiful sit-down dinner
with performances scattered throughout
because all the entire um party was
seated at like this big it was about 100
people and the tables were set up in
like a semi-circle around this big stage
so first came out um the star of this
Broadway show that time I told you that
you would love it Titanic she's really
like this world-class Celine Dion
impersonator and so she sang Celine Dion
and she did like little stand-up it was
so funny great that was appetizers then
entree was Shangela who if you don't
know she's like one of the biggest stars
come out of RuPaul's Drag Race she was
just on Dancing With the Stars and she
um
what's so crazy is like she went home
like so early on an old season but like
she just stayed in the franchise and she
came back on All-Stars and she's really
she's amazing and she did like a bunch
of Beyonce and then we had dessert and
then came the main event which nobody
knew I didn't know but nobody knew so
like when they announced like next
performance is going to be Kim Petras
like when I tell you the room which was
mostly gay men Jackie they were not okay
they were not okay screaming
screaming Kim Petrus came out and gave
such an unbelievable performance I am
obsessed with Kim Petras and I've been
doing like my homework since I found out
like a month ago that she was going to
be the performer just making sure I knew
all the words to all the songs
um she was incredible her voice
she's like she is going to be like an IT
girl pop star like she was so amazing
her songs are so good her vocals were so
good and she was so cool afterwards like
you know she could have left but she
stayed for the party and I just have to
say like major shout out too
the toaster nation that is everywhere
because Kim petrus's assistant was the
biggest toaster so I got to meet Kim we
took pictures we hung out at the party
and like I like to think it's because
like Kim and it was my work but mostly
it was because her assistant like was
like she's the toast like she's a big
deal and it was like shout out toaster
Nation like saving lives everywhere they
go I spent literally the whole night
meet with Kim Petros like I peeked I
literally peaked and headline news not
one but two of your arms were out oh
yeah by the way this was like a crazy
weekend for me because one of the nights
I literally wore a strapless dress my
arms have not seen the light of day
probably since the sixth grade they were
looking really good I felt good I got a
spray tan which always helps did you
have more fun because like you weren't
as hot Jackie that's what I wanted to
come out here and say because on
Saturday night I wore my arms out and on
Sunday on a Friday night I wore my arms
and on Saturday night I wore my hair in
a bun
it's liberating and those are two things
I vowed to never do but it's you know
the year of yes we're saying yes and the
way my night was so different because of
it my arms were free I was dancing
dancing non-stop dancing DJ dancing
performance dancing screaming and I
wasn't sweating and I'm always sweating
but because my arms were free like I was
just lighter and then the night that I
wore my hair up was the night of the the
roast and the roast was in this like
really like small like hot club my hair
was up I didn't even that one I didn't
have to take a shower not one drip of
sweat I am obsessed with wearing my hair
up now I I can't believe those words are
coming out of my mouth like yeah I saw
some pictures that made me like want to
jump off a bridge but you know what I
wasn't sweating and I feel like that's
the payoff like sometimes I'll see
pictures of myself with my hair down but
I'm sweating so much that I hate the
picture so now it's like all right I
have my hair up from the side I got like
you know three necks but I'm not
sweating so like it's a it's a give it a
take no and like when your hair's down
and you're sweating like your hair
doesn't look good no and you put your
hair up anyway it's not looking it's not
good hair it's stuck to you it's not
doing anything for anyone okay so add it
to the list Downton reading Yellowstone
succession wearing your hair up which
I've been trying to tell everyone have
you yeah like I wore my hair up at my
wedding reception yeah and I it was the
key to having a great night
it's the key to having a great night I
know I brought my little wax and it's a
little facelift too like you will look
more snatched in the face when your hair
is up because you have to pull back
especially if you do like a hardcore
slick hard I had my wax stick I was
waxing all over the place and people are
like oh man she got plastic surgery she
looks so different I literally have not
gotten plastic surgery I haven't even
got my lips done in a while like I only
get BOTOX in my forehead forehead
whatever
um I have no plan I looked so snatched
the wax stick is the key to the bun
though yeah and just like you know not
having postpartum regrowth yeah no the
hair I'm not postpartum and I don't have
regrowth but I got the craziest little
hairs around my ears oh I have
those two I've always said yeah they
just
they are what they are they are what
they are have a bobby pin on hand so you
know what it was an amazing trip I'm
exhausted I really never got on Lisbon
time because we were out so late every
night and
I don't even know what time it is I'm so
disoriented I slept through my alarm
today I'm working on getting back onto
American time
I'm happy to be back in the States
because there's no Diet Coke in Lisbon
that's like my one note for the country
but again that's just a European thing
um I'm grateful I'm I'm I had the best
time like it was and I felt really good
about like my outfits and I got such
good pictures and I made so many good
tick tocks like I'd like three or four
tick tocks that went viral like I had
one that got a million damn right before
the shutdown that's that's like a big
that's like a successful weekend yeah no
that that really is and how was our
little sister I got to spend time with
our little sister which it was
definitely giving cool crowd it was
giving like we were the cool girls you
know I felt like you know a mean
skinny girl that you are now I know it's
such a good feeling it's a life
um it was it was amazing like I I feel
like pictures didn't even do it justice
Brian did such a good job like every
detail uh I will say though Portuguese
food is not for me I know that's
probably shocks nobody
um I literally had McDonald's four times
because it was a McDonald's and they
have ubereats in Lisbon oh my God
obsessed
um I had McDonald's pretty much every
day eventually I'm not the type of
person who like eats poorly and then
it's like oh I feel gross I'm like no
give me more but it was like back to
back of literally only eating McDonald's
I feel like like I feel lethargic I feel
like a gorilla I feel terrible I know
it's so real how eating healthy meats
you feel good and eating poorly like
that's what it just shouldn't be though
everyone's been trying to tell us all
this time and until you experience it
like Zach and I were driving I was
really hungry and there was McDonald's
he was like do you want to go I was like
no because then I will feel so awful oh
my God like a slob I feel like I've got
this like I need to like make a big Duty
obviously I didn't Duty once while I was
in Lisbon like that's so may uh you need
your seed I need a lot maybe if you had
your seed and you were taking your seed
you would know what it's like to make a
big duty but you don't no yeah that's
that's definitely coming my way this
week which I'm excited about
it was amazing I'm I'm so happy to be
back at home because traveling is so
hard you know eight hour flight but so
worth it like really
such Brian really out like it was next
level it was beyond what I was expecting
yeah and I expect a lot from him it
looked amazing and then I came home just
in time last night to catch the second
half of the Oscars which is like where
everything good happened oh great
because that's what by the time I turned
it off so together we watched the whole
thing two halves make a hole two halves
make a hole we'll be recapping the
Oscars Story number one
so I guess we could get into it well
before we do major shout outs so while
there was no toast episodes on Thursday
and Friday Jackie and I pre-recorded an
episode for Thursday so if you were
missing out on content you got to hear
Jackie and I do a podcast episode on
Thursday and then on Friday we were
supposed to record but like I never got
on New York time I could not make time
to podcast so I brought my mic with me
but Jackie ended up recording an episode
at home with her and Zach and Zach
hasn't been on the podcast in many years
two years we did the math so they did a
major update with mamersons and people
were loving it like I feel like I'm
about to be replaced you know they were
just loving the kid like I feel like we
gave some good advice like it was just
very realistic for like postpartum
relationship yeah um
and yeah no it was fun to have him back
on it was so different from all the
other episodes that we've done because
like Everything's changed in our lives
so it was good to catch up with him
everyone you know
was able to hear where he's at and where
we're at and it was really fun actually
we it was a positive podcasting
experience with your husband like really
so rare I wasn't irritated at all like
really nothing bothered me which is
crazy because it always does no like
podcasting with Ben is a full-blown
panic yeah what's he gonna say what's he
gonna say yeah or he just is like you
know they do things that are just
that don't work for podcasts and I feel
not instead of saying yes it's like this
is an audio show no totally State your
answer sir so if you were a patreon
member this last weekend I hope that
came in clutch for you while I was gone
thank you guys for giving me the space
to take two days off Jax thanks for
holding it down yeah welcome and now
we're back another gorgeous full week of
the toast here another one another one
okay so without further Ado
time for the fastest stories that you
need to know
and to the past five stories that you
absolutely need to know are brought to
you by Honey the easy way to save When
shopping on your iPhone or computer
thanks to Honey manually searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shipping tool excuse
me free shopping tool oh my God I'm not
okay that scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best one it finds
to your cart so if you shop online which
you obviously do and you're not using
honey like what are you doing I feel
like The Toasters actually told us about
honey many many years ago and I
downloaded the browser extension all
that all that time ago I still use it
and now you can use it on your phone
when you're shopping online on Safari so
it works on your iPhone just activated
on your Safari on your iPhone and you
can save money on the go here's how
honey Works once you download it you're
shopping at one of your favorite
websites when you check out the honey
button will appear and all you have to
do is Click apply coupons wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
that it can find and if honey finds a
working coupon go watch the prices drop
so long gone are the days where you'd
have to like Google like promo code for
this website and like try 100 different
ones before you found one that works 100
only does it all for you in seconds
saving you money saving you time there's
literally no reason not to download it
because when you use our link you'll
doubt you'll get the browser extension
for free it's a free free browser
extension that saves you money like what
are you doing seriously
so if you don't already have honey you
are straight up missing out by getting
it you're doing yourself a solid and
you'll of course be supporting the toast
so get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com toast I have saved money
on clothing food Electronics literally
everything in my house I've saved money
on from honey that's joinhoney.com toast
today's episode is also sponsored by
Third love most bras suck and it's a
real bummer and third love knows that
it's not you it's the bra third love
spent years designing bras for your body
and they make over 60 sizes and they
even invented half cup sizes so you'll
always get the perfect fit which means
you'll always look and feel great when I
first started using honey like four
years ago now I realized what had been
my problem this whole time and it was I
didn't know my correct bra size because
I feel like I got measured once in a
mall like 15 years ago and I've just
been using that as a reference point
ever since and their fit finder quiz is
so accurate it's crazy they ask really
detailed questions and because they
invented those half cup sizes like you
will get the most specific size for your
bra because we all got different tips
okay why would we all use same sizes so
if you're looking for an everyday bra
something with more coverage and online
style a little extra lift all of the
above check out thirdlove's best-selling
bras part of the reason I was able to go
strapless this weekend in Portugal is
because I have a fabulous well-fitting
strapless bra from third love they're
all designed to fit and support your
body they have a style for every
solution and they will make you look and
feel great in whatever you're wearing
again those half cup sizes are available
so you will be sure to find your size
after taking the quiz it will change
your life like knowing what real size
your boobs are is a life-changing fact
that it shouldn't be so hard to find and
thanks to third love it's not so ditch
the bad bras get a better one that makes
you look and feel great upgrade your bra
and get 20 off your first order at
thirdlove.com toast that's 20 off your
first order today when you go to
thirdlove.com
t-o-a-s-t thanks third love thanks third
love
turd love love
hearts first story Oscar's recap we have
the list of winners we have our personal
thoughts on the proceedings I turned it
off right after Rihanna's performance
when did you turn it on
a little bit before Rihanna's
performance so we we got the whole gamut
covered Okay cool so here's the winners
list and the categories that you care
about because they literally announced
every single Dreadful category last
night and was so boring yeah no
there was like a real lull when they
were like you know of course you know
people behind the scenes in the movies
deserve all the recognition but like
maybe that's like you know the pre-show
Awards because you know we're tuning in
for the Stars no it was so much adapted
screenplay original screenplay
cinematography editing like it was yeah
it was a lot visual effects
best picture the big Award of the night
went to everything everywhere all at
once that really was the sweeper of
awards yeah they won everything they
turned it off I was getting the vibe
that um All Quiet on the Western Front
was sweeping no when I turned it on it
was like literally supporting actress
supporting actor uh supported actress
lead actor it was literally director
everything yeah no like they wound up
sweeping but I from what I saw like I
thought All Quiet on the Western Front
was winning everything and then I guess
they stopped winning once I turned it
off like so they were nominated for 12
Oscars and I believe they won seven
which is crazy best actor Brendan
Frazier the whale that was really that
was emotional for everyone in the room
and
it's just a beautiful I know I did say
if he didn't win the Oscar I would get a
bob but you know me I'm always saying
crazy things and I'm not getting a bob
so don't try me
um I honestly thought it was like so not
possible that he would win that's why I
said it but with each award he won the
SAG like he kept winning them and I felt
like the Oscars you know was always
trying to be different so he actually
wasn't gonna win
but he did and Claudia that's beautiful
I felt like he was gonna win it's worth
noting neither of us have seen the movie
still no no but I did see last week that
it's available to rent on YouTube which
means that it's like on demand
everywhere and you could watch it at
home yeah last weekend me and Ben stayed
in on Saturday night and I put the
trailer on on iTunes I'm like let's
watch this and we watched a trailer and
honestly it looks so sad and
depressing I'm like I'm trying I stayed
in tonight like I I want to enjoy my
night not ruin it I need you need to be
in a very specific headspace to watch a
film that sad yeah
I just feel like if we didn't watch it
before last night like now our odds are
even lower a hundred percent but I do
want to watch it still I know I know
best actress Michelle yo everything
everywhere all at once obsessed like
she's so the moment right now
she looked beautiful her and Jamie Lee
Curtis's friendship is really cute and I
just feel like everyone who worked on
that movie was crying the whole night
like cry cry I know it was really sweet
made me want to watch the movie because
like I'll watch a sweep
me too except when I went on my journey
to start watching Oscar's movies which I
did watch a few I watched the trailer
for that one and it so looked like
something I'd never want to watch again
very Matrix parallel universe that's not
my my cup of tea I know but a sweep
it's worth taking this week a sweep is
an endorsement and you're the sweeper so
you should watch it sweet 100
best supporting actor kihai Kwan
everything everywhere all at once every
time this guy makes a speech it's like
more beautiful than the last one which
isn't even possible because he brings a
tear to every eye in the room and I'm
just so here for the elders winning
Oscars like oh my God it was the evening
of the elders I was so thrilled people
who's like you know who either got like
really late starts in the business or
have been like really like even Jamie
Lou Curtis she's been in this in this
business for 40 years and she finally
won like I feel like last night was kind
of like delayed gratification for a lot
of people yeah best supporting actress
Jamie Lee Curtis you are all of us
everything everywhere all at once I
could not stop Jamie Lee Curtis you are
all alone no but what was so crazy was
Ariana Dubose yes presented for best
supporting actor and best supporting
actress and she had to announce all of
the nominees and I was like Angela
Bassett did the thing I really thought
she was gonna reference self-reference
the rap
she did not which was disappointing but
she still brought her Ariana Dubose
Flair to the presentation they did not
kill her spirit you guys no they did it
but she did do something that like kind
of like annoyed me which was when she
announced he had Quan had one
um she like opened the envelope and
started sobbing and it's like okay it's
not about you like just say the name and
then like let the person get on stage
she was like okay like stop like it's so
dramatic you're not his mother like no I
agree and I don't know of one but I'm
not sure there's a clear like personal
relationship establishing how they work
together in a movie I don't think so
just like you know having admiration for
a great actor I think that's what it is
like the enormous respect people have
for like you know he's spent time in a
refugee camp and to make it all the way
to the Oscars he and he said in a speech
like that stuff only happens in movies
and you know what it doesn't even happen
in movies like it's so
wild and I just I don't know that kind
of like read me the wrong way it's like
being a presenter it's like really
supposed to be like very it's not about
you I really feel that okay I do agree
so I just like I found that annoying
best animated film Guillermo del Toros
Pinocchio
it made me want to see that any sometime
in my life
um skipping the next few categories to
best original score which is always an
interesting category because there were
some really good composers nominated but
All Quiet on the Western Front One
War Tings best original song so let's
talk about all the performances because
no no before we talk about the
performances we have did you see his
speech
no I didn't oh my God Jackie you would
have cried I know I would have Jackie he
said the cutest thing he was like you
don't understand like growing up I loved
the Carpenters
and the Carpenters sing that song among
the top of the word Jackie he started to
sing that song on top of the world but
he made his own lyrics about how he's
you know so proud to be here and he's
doing this for all the Indians and he
ended it and he's like now I'm on the
top of the world it was so cute me in
bed were crying like in that moment I
wanted Lady Gaga to win but once I heard
that speech I was so grateful that she
didn't because his speech was the cutest
thing I'd ever seen in my entire
life so I was feeling really conflicted
at the beginning of the night I wanted
Lady Gaga to win because hold my hand
has be has is my favorite song out of
all of these songs when I saw the
performance for not to not to did you
see it no it was amazing it was it felt
like I was on a Broadway 42nd Street
show glamor glamor glamor dancing
everything it was ensemble cast like it
was a taste of a movie that I now want
to see like it had everything the song
was so good and upbeat and I was like I
understand now why this song keeps
winning I and I hope that they win again
because the performance was so amazing
and it was a history making win and then
I also saw Rihanna's performance and I
love the song even more when she sang it
last night agreed and I was like oh this
could win the Oscar too so it was so
interesting how like the performances
kind of um changed my perception of who
should and shouldn't win because at
first I was like honestly I don't think
Rihanna's really a contender I didn't
think the song was that powerful but
then like seeing her perform it I was
like damn like she was amazing her
vocals were on point she looked
she looked amazing and then like I have
not stopped talking about how this Lady
Gaga song is the best song literary of
the year uh movie or otherwise and that
performance was not for me like not at
all I do I love stripped down acoustic
no makeup chap lips version like I love
but what the was that okay so she
literally changed the entire song like
there weren't even like hints of a
similar Melody really like hate
by the end of it I came away saying like
that was really good I thought she
sounded really good and I either she was
going through something or she was you
know
putting on an emotional performance
which she does yeah this is her like
artist thing yeah but like if I didn't
know better I would say Oh Lady Gaga's
kind of like going through it because
she seemed so so she was grasping to
this song and when she talked about how
it's about like having a role model or a
hero it was very AC American camper
talking about counselor snitch like
I don't know yeah it was not for me like
by any stretch I was like actually
disappointed
I'm gonna change your perspective
because she wasn't supposed to perform
until like literally yesterday and so
she got together with her Peeps and she
put on something she obviously wasn't
gonna have you know
oh my God I literally like I'm about to
reference
something what a line from like and I'm
like what's that from it's from like one
of Harry's books oh
what is it brass bands play balloons
float High the city looks so Grand I
know you mean like glamor yeah like the
all the
um instruments and stuff that like
Rihanna had you know she put it together
with her peeps from the basement and she
gave us the performance and I'm grateful
for that and she sounded really good it
wasn't the performance I would have
wanted to hear but I thought it was
still really amazing yeah
not for me and her Red Carpet look was
maybe my favorite oh stunning maybe my
favorite loved Rihanna's red carpet look
too but her stage look was even better
uh dripping in Jewels like it was so
sickening so
um neither of them won and instead not
two not two one which uh I'm so on the
performance in the speech I'm very happy
about that yeah like I wouldn't have had
it any other way yeah and then a bunch
of other stuff won congrats to everyone
congrats everyone there was a lot of
stars there who um like Miles Teller and
Kelly teller were there which was so
nice you know supporting the Top Gun
even though he wasn't nominated they
looked
there are no words that
Visionary yeah Visions
um and there was also like some drama
that came out of the night first was you
know I don't know if you saw Angela
bassett's um reaction when Jamie Lee
Curtis won I did and now I'm seeing all
the Recaps right I don't think it's
really fair to judge like what she's
thinking based on that moment because of
course everyone wants to win that
doesn't mean you're not happy for
someone else but it was almost like her
look was like she didn't even expect to
win like she knew you know I thought she
was gonna win I thought she was gonna
win two but I also feel like the Oscars
are like very anti and I think this year
more than ever they included a lot of
like those big budget not not marvely
but like Blockbuster like black panther
popular I feel like that you know oh
you're you did well in the box office
kid talk to you like they're very
artisty
um and I feel like this year more than
ever they really included a lot of those
like big budget movies so I just feel
like they have something against those
types of movies which is why Angela
Bassett didn't win yeah
that's very possible I feel like you're
it's less of an oscarry role right I
also feel like Angela bassett's reaction
to like not winning like she doesn't
need to stand up and cry that Jesus one
like to me that is a sign of someone
who's not happy as opposed to someone
else who's just like okay I didn't win
okay yeah moving on moving on yeah let's
get this camera out of my face I don't
need to now act again like I'm happy
like I'm so over the moon for this
person when like of course I'd rather be
me duh That should be me and like you
don't need to stand for everything I'm
sorry it should be it should mean
something when there's a standing
ovation facts facts and then when
everybody stands when one person wins
it's because like the whole room is
rooting for this person like if we're
just gonna stand for everyone why don't
we just all sit so true and it's like
everyone's wearing big gowns and big
shoes it's like we have to get up every
10 seconds right and now I have to get
up when I lost like No And so I I
actually kind of appreciate her just
like
just like sitting say literally
relatable what did you think about Jimmy
Kimmel as a host oh I had a lot of
thoughts I missed the first few minutes
of his monologue but I came in for the
rest of it and I thought that actually
some of the jokes were really funny but
the way that he delivered them felt like
amateur night like he would just do like
one joke at a time like and then look
around like it really felt like an
amateur comedian who was actually
delivering decent jokes yeah I agree I
don't know what he would have joked
about if not for Will Smith and like
it's so funny how this year it's like
the slap the slap the slap when like
when it actually happened like you all
just sat there you all did nothing and
you all gave him an Oscar right
afterwards and that was actually like a
fire point from Jimmy Kimmel it was but
it's like
you guys like it you're talking to like
yeah yeah I know you mean so
um it was like I guess good that he made
light of it but it was also felt like a
crotchet for every single joke but there
were some other jokes in the beginning
that were just like throwaway jokes that
I thought were really that were really
well written and funny just he was
delivering them like a noob
I agree I thought a lot of the jokes
were really funny when he made the joke
about I forget who it was I think it was
the director no
I forget who it was somebody I didn't
know how he you know he actually didn't
get into filmmaking until he was in his
late 40s and before that he was a civil
engineer for and basically built the
roads of LA
and he's like it's so amazing that
you're one of the greatest directors of
all time and one of the worst civil
engineers of all time because the roads
in LA are Abyss I'm butchering the joke
but it was very funny I agree a lot of
the jokes were like really smart and
funny and I enjoyed a lot of them he was
better than I thought and I was like a
big hater before yeah uh people are
roasting him because he like joked
around with Malala oh by the way
I agree I watched it it was
weird Malala was not down she was not
down but like I don't think that he's
like a horrible person for trying to
like make jokes with Malala like she
came to the Oscars like we're gonna have
a laugh we're gonna attempt one I no I
agree like it was definitely awkward but
she like made it awkward and it's like
well what are you doing at the Oscars
anyway like it was like a
you went like you have to dive in yeah
yeah this isn't like the Nobel Peace
award it's like this is the Oscars It's
Entertainment we're on TV here like
right I'm gonna make a joke I'm gonna
throw it in Malala do without what you
will it was definitely like weird that
they wrote a thing to like you know joke
with Malala because she's literally like
an activist who was shot in the face
like I don't know if that's like you
know the vibe but she she should have
leaned in but I don't think she like
culturally like I don't think she knows
what the no like I don't think so
either but I actually thought her answer
was like perfect for the question and
perfect for Malala because he was like
do you think Harry Styles spit on Chris
Pine and she was like I only talk about
peace peace but like she looks
uncomfortable and everyone around looked
uncomfortable and he did this where
he would like give the microphone then
he did Colin Farrell and then he did
Jessica Chastain and these you know
actors are gonna make it a moment say
the funniest thing they could think of
him a lot I was like I don't know I just
talk about peas yeah no I I it didn't
the execution wasn't like a plus but I
think the ideation like oh malala's here
let's have a laugh with Malala like why
not get Malala involved yeah Malala
likes to joke too she came to the Oscars
like she's not completely anti she
looked glamorous she did I loved what
she was wearing so I
thought it was funny I I hope yeah I
hope she like wasn't offended but I I
don't think he I think he was just like
you know being silly and I I think it's
a funny concept like let's joke around
with Malala 100 about like nonsensical
Hollywood things right I'm sure Malala
could actually use a reprieve from her
kind of from her serious work yeah to
just some you know let's lighten it up
with lighten it up with Malala new
podcast literally
um and then the other big drama
everyone's talking about that I actually
have a lot of thoughts on is the Hugh
Grant yes I saw that here so on a major
uh Network which was ABC right yep they
had Ashley Graham Vanessa Hudgins and
Lily Singh as their three correspondents
um and they would go back and forth
everyone got a new person and and Ashley
Graham had the great displeasure
um of interviewing Hugh Grant who I
presume wanted to be anywhere else but
that Podium because you know and I'm
gonna be totally honest was Ashley
Graham asking like the most in you know
thought-provoking genius questions no
was Hugh Grant being a prick yes
so if you watch the clip he's so
disinterested he thinks he literally is
standing there thinking that Ashley
Graham is dumb like I know like that's
literally what's going to do his mind he
rolled his eyes at the end he's giving
one word answers she's so desperately
trying to claw like a forward answer out
of him and she just ends up being like
well what are you wearing like there was
just she got through all of her
questions that should have taken five
minutes and it took 25 seconds because
he was like yeah uh no I enjoyed it cool
yeah he definitely was not an easy
subject to be interviewing but I just
wonder like if this if the person doing
the interviewing was like an actual host
how they would have pivoted the
conversation you know because she really
asked one question like are you so
excited to be here and he was like
pretty much no and then she said so what
are you excited about today like and
it's like well he's not excited
so ask a different question and so and
then she went to literally the lowest
question on the red carpet which is who
and what are you wearing and it's like
when the combo when you're clearly
talking to someone you need to match
their energy and like yeah he was being
an but like that's the job of
the host is to like find some common
ground and like the hosts of your like
would do extensive okay research on
everybody who's coming through also like
I mean maybe it's not on her to see
every single movie but he was in
gothamion for literally two seconds he
opened the door yeah
so my thoughts are very similar like
half of me is like he was a prick but
then the other half of me is like what
the is going on at ABC this is the
biggest night in cinema this isn't like
a pop award show where you can get away
with like surface level questions like
this is all about art and film and what
the do you have three
non-journalist celebrities doing as your
correspondents like what happened to the
Ryan Seacrest Jason Kennedy cat Sadler
professional interviewees like we have a
YouTuber a Disney actress and a model
being red carpet interviews for the
Oscars okay that was the People's Choice
Awards I love it but like I kind of
understand Hugh Grant's like this Oscar
is like it feels like a farce like it's
like these aren't thought-provoking
questions these aren't people who know a
lot about the film The cinematography
like or who aren't well researched so I
did feel bad for Ashley Graham because
she was just doing her job and she was
really at a higher level what the
are is the thought process Behind these
three people being chosen as the
official ABC on TV correspondence agreed
and I think she did as best a job as she
could because she was really sweet and
she kept her positivity and like she was
smiling and then she just like ushered
him off when she like got through the
four questions that she had for him but
like the problem is that she only had
four questions for him in her like
Rolodex of questions and they were
extremely surface level
nonsensical questions when you're
talking to like this is the serious
actors awards show no this is like a
really legit thing and so two things can
be true like Hugh Grant can be a dick
but I'm you know his point wasn't lost
on me like it's a kind of like a circus
what's going on here yeah I want to go
back to the days and I feel like he is
experiencing this because they've gotten
a lot of really negative feedback about
Laverne Cox and I love Laverne Cox as an
actress and just as like a human being
but her questions are like so
moronic and everyone's like what's the
story behind your outfit that's what she
says to everyone it's like what happened
to the day right like what happened to
the days of you know every award show
like every Network having their people
yeah like and I feel like yeah in the
digital age like we've moved into like
more influency type people but there's a
lot like I feel like kelty's such a
great like kelty's one of those OG
interview Entertainment Tonight like she
knows everything about everyone she
reads those binders for weeks she's
gonna study day and night but when you
have someone who's like a model or an
actress or has other jobs like it's not
their primary job to like know all of
this stuff so then they show up they
have probably the thing in their ear and
they have you know they have the briefs
but you need like extensive knowledge to
be able to pull questions out of thin
air with people who don't want to give
you anything it's not an easy job I
think people think it's so easy let's
put our favorite celebrity in there
because they have fun conversations but
like there's a reason why this is a
profession and yes most of the time
people are able to conversate and you
can have fun and like a celebrity is you
know give it a little bit more open and
giving you more than you expected but
like
you're trained for moments like this and
they're not trained agreed hashtag bring
back the journalists like I don't know
whatever it's happened on every Network
and I I don't really having a person who
is the interviewee interviewer be a
celebrity themselves like makes no sense
yeah like the the interviewer is
supposed to be like representative of
the people you know yeah a nobody we
need a commoner a professional
journalist a professional an
entertainment journalist like there
should be there's so many that's
everyone's dream job yeah so I agree
with that I will say though I only saw
this clip I don't know how the rest of
the carpet went for her she might have
been amazing she was fine she wasn't
amazing everyone was fine but it's like
I just think on a whole we've taken this
like you know
this thing a little far where we've
actually literally
totally excluded actual celebrity
entertainment journalists right and also
like what about someone with a comedy
background because like when you like
who these questions are bombing they
have experience in bombing and like
being on stage and like getting them and
shifting and yeah yeah it's a Miss for
me I think we need to actually go back
in time because there was a time where
red carpets especially on E like they
were killing it like Joan I mean that's
the gold standard Joan is a gold
standard obviously not everyone's gonna
be Joan but like we should aspire to
Joan Joan of course but then also even
after Jonah was like the the Staples
Ryan Seacrest Giuliana say what you want
about her she was good and she
studied yeah no I I'm not like she had
some awkward moments but
she always had like a question a person
and she always knew everything about
everyone in their projects and what they
had going on and I don't know if that
was something in her ear but she did a
good job and I feel like e is now doing
like that next Generation with like
Justin Sylvester Adrian Bailon
um Kelty and I don't know why you know
they wouldn't put the Tanya rad I don't
know why they wouldn't put those people
on the carpet
instead they have um Laverne Cox and I'm
not trying to say any I love Laverne Cox
but it's not her strongest
who did the e-red carpet last night I
didn't watch you I don't know um you
didn't see any Clips or anything no
tic-tock hasn't caught up I'm not sure
um anyways I do feel bad for Ashley
Graham but it's the same it's a really
hard position to be put in
and
that's why people's job is this 100
so any other Oscar's thoughts no overall
it was it was good it was fine it was it
wasn't like the most amazing thing I'd
ever seen no it was positively Dreadful
honestly and the all the categories they
brought back all the categories because
I guess last year some of them were
offline and people were upset I don't
know who
um so they brought all the categories
and like every 30 minutes there was like
an ad for ABC W Warner Brothers 100
anniversary did you I don't think you
saw this stuff but it was an ad for the
little mermaid like a trailer which by
the way looked really good but um excuse
me that's what commercial breaks are for
it's like they wanted to make the show
as long as possible said we are in no
rush yeah well they're on La time so
they wouldn't be in any rush but for us
it's almost midnight wrap it up yeah
wrap it up
um before we dive in let me just tell
you how our next couple of stories are
brought to you by nutrifall did you know
30 million women are impacted by
weakened or thinning hair if you're
among them no you're not alone and that
there's a solution that you can trust to
deliver results nutrifall is the number
one dermatologist recommended hair
growth supplement clinically shown to
improve your hair growth the thickness
and visible scalp coverage you know I
spoke about this on my Instagram
recently I've been dealing with like
crazy shedding like every time I run my
fingers through my hair there's like so
like more than normal and I know a lot
of it has to do with like a recent
change in my diet and so when I was like
asking around for like some of my
friends who have dealt with like hair
loss everyone recommended nutrifall it's
such like a it's like a really like a
brand you can trust
um and I've had really good
um results with it so neutrophone
supports healthy hair growth from within
by targeting the five root causes of
thinning hair which can be stress
hormones environment nutrition and
Metabolism nutrifall has three unique
formulas to support women throughout all
stages of life including postpartum and
menopause each formula is physician
formulated using natural drug-free
medical grade ingredients in
consistently effective dosages so you
get the most reliable results in a
clinical study 86 percent of women
reported improved hair growth after six
months and over three thousand Top
Doctors and stylists recommended
nutrifall as an effective and high
quality solution for healthier hair so
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrifall.com enter promo code toast to
save 15 off your first month's
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it's only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order so get that 15
off at nutrifall.com
promo code toast today's episode is also
brought to you by Squarespace
for websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business so if you're looking
to build a website but you don't know
where to start check out Squarespace
they have amazing tools to help you get
your business off the ground whether
you're starting a side hustle you work
in e-commerce they have fabulous tools
especially for e-commerce because
Squarespace is the space to sell
everything and anything Squarespace has
the tools that you need to get your
business off the ground including
e-commerce templates inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace has merchandising features
to make your products look their best
online they also have video blocks ways
to connect your social media accounts
traffic overviews and content ownership
so you own all the content you put on
squarespace's platform because they
offer a one-click data portability so
check out squarespace.com toast for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code toast to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain so whatever reason you might
be wanting to build a website and you
don't know where to start it can be
really intimidating you know if you
don't have like a software engine
engineering or a computer science
background Squarespace is a great place
to start you can build a beautiful
website it takes really not a long time
and it'll look super professional and no
one will know like Squarespace did
everything for you
um and then you'll also get really good
insights into your analytics your
traffic overview where people are going
to your website from how much time
they're spending on the website so again
use the offer code toast at
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and once you're ready to launch use the
code toast to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain thank
you Claudia you're welcome our next
story Little rumor that could be true
could be not the 2023 Met Gala could be
Kardashian free
the mechalic could be Kardashian free
this year after the whole family of
reality stars attended in Mass for the
first time in 2022 sources tell page six
that Vogue boss Anna and tour is
cracking down on the guest list at the
annual fashion vet and that no
Kardashians will make the cut Vogue
wouldn't comment on the events guest
list when they reached out but a source
familiar with the qurashing Jenner Clan
says that it's not true that they
weren't invited to the big ball so some
people saying they're not invited other
people saying they're invited still the
story is kind of weird and out of
nowhere and it just is making me
consider the veracity yeah I feel like I
feel like there actually is a world in
which a lot of the Kardashians don't go
to the Met Gala this year
um well oh it's what it's in like two
months right it's March and it's in May
yeah so I don't know because they're in
like this weird space right now like
they're being very like low-key and
quiet because they're kind of like
coming off the heels of a lot of like
negativity and people are just like not
feeling them right now
um I don't really see a world in which
Anna Wintour like banned the Kardashians
because to be honest for the last few
years a lot of people have exclusively
only cared because that because they
were there and I think that wouldn't be
smart but I do see a world in which
she's like you know getting really
strict on who they allow in because I
feel like the last year or two it's kind
of like a free-for-all like some of the
people I'm like how the did you get
here it didn't seem all that exclusive
yeah I think that they should crack down
on the list the last few years it hasn't
been that cool seeming but I think the
Kardashians are not the problem with
that they're actually kind of the
solution they have so many friends in
Hollywood all of their friends are like
fellow a-listers like Haley Bieber like
you know their Network they should be
there I think they make the party really
fun and I think that they're all going
to be there Kim is definitely going to
be there with Dolce Gabbana like oh yeah
they're all like Kendall is an actual
model she's going to be there I think
Kendall yeah Kylie was just like fashion
girly in Milan I think and Kendall and
Kylie last night went to Vanity Fair
right and they're like in there like
going out fashion girlies era they're
100 going now maybe
Chloe isn't dying to go again maybe
Courtney I could see that like her being
like Oh I it I went it was okay I don't
need to go back I just said actually
Courtney not being invited back I felt
like the last time she was I remember on
the car but she was like kind of rude
yeah Chris always goes with Tommy
Hilfiger who is still her friend so
unless Adam literally says to Tommy you
can't invite Chris like Chris will be
there I don't think this is true
I mean we'll have to wait and see
um I don't think it's true that none of
them because you're right like
definitely Kim and Kendall I feel like
are always 100 guaranteed to go one
because Kim is so fashioned and Kendall
is obviously like a very high fashion
supermodel Kylie like sometimes doesn't
leave her house so like I could see her
not going and then but Kylie is in her
leaving her house era she's literally so
snatched right now she's oh wait she
she's like stepping out in all these
fashion looks recently like yeah Chia
Pirelli and all that stuff she was
wearing like she's loving it she like is
so
skinny right now for lack of a better
word and she's gonna go with
mechala yeah I mean but she also like
does you know sometimes not go to things
so I'm saying like her not going isn't
like she wasn't invited but like I see
sometimes she doesn't go like
remember like she had a sore throat so
she didn't go to Bama and like she
sometimes skips stuff so I could see
whether she's skinny or not I can see
her not going but I don't think I'm
saying I don't think that would mean
that she wasn't invited by Anna
got it okay fine
but now that this rumors out there I
feel like like now they're gonna go all
of them
you know no I feel like even only one
one or two have to go to dispel the
rumor because the rumor is that none of
them are invited to Kardashian free
Affair so yeah that's either true or
false because minimum we really always
get Kendall Kim and Chris yes and I
think we will again and I really think
Kylie will be there
me too I don't know about Chloe and
Courtney I hope Chloe's there I hope
Chloe said I hope she had fun last time
but I didn't get the vibe that she did
because she said she had a lot of
anxiety about those things yeah I don't
think she had a bad time I think it was
like very nerve-wracking I think
Courtney like had a bad time like when
she was being interviewed she was like
this is weird yeah yeah I could see her
being like I don't need to go again and
I could see her not being invited
because she didn't like appear to be
grateful to be there and her outfit kind
of sunk big brown skirt yeah but do you
think I feel like Anna
would weirdly like not care about
someone who's like acting too cool for
the event that's like better than
someone who's acting like desperate for
it true you know what I mean
honestly I hope that this rumor is not
true but maybe it's like a misconstrued
rumor about how they're just you know
becoming way more strict about who can
come because it should be that it should
be that there are all of these like
random like
yeah what's like young Hollywood people
who are yes in today but they're not
like a list it's really not an A-list
event anymore no it became like a little
mainstream but I also understand like
the last few years were confusing with
covert and people who could come and
couldn't come and like the vaccine thing
so then I think a lot of people didn't
go that year so they had to bring in the
B team and this is by the way that is
true and you know there were a lot of
blind items about celebs making like
fake vaccine cards just to get into the
macella yeah they were like
fake vaccines but I think I think lot of
celebrities also didn't get vaccinated
because they're like oh by the way one
nobody talks about how like definitely
half of Hollywood is not vaccinated
they're so green and like yeah like
they're not putting stuff in their body
right there's no way I know for
a fact nobody in Hollywood is vaccinated
like it's literally logic hello yeah so
I think
um are they still is it you have to be
vaccinated no because there's not that
law in New York anymore oh right oh
right it wasn't me Gala it was new it
was just events in general events events
that want to go to events
then so I want to go to events invite me
to your events oh you're right so maybe
it'll be maybe less b-list I think even
last may you didn't need a vaccine
because you didn't in New York then so
anyways the last few years have been a
hodgepodge plus there was like two in
one year because there was September and
may yep I think this year comes a fresh
I think Anna like she's like okay the
nonsense covid you know the tabula rasa
yeah everyone like had an excuse then
then to get tested and all this stuff
like tabula rasa let's get back to the
A-list
I think that's good yeah maybe that that
policy got misconstrued to page six as
the Kardashians aren't invited yeah like
or maybe yeah they were probably like
they're you know taking out the trash
and maybe page six interpreted that as
the Kardashians but you know whether you
want to admit it or not and I feel like
a lot of really like high fashion people
who are like into art and fashion and
culture like hate on the Kardashians but
to deny their influence on American
fashion it would be is moronic like you
it's you literally can't ignore them no
and like Anna tried it it didn't work
out I don't think she's gonna go back to
ignoring them
and they've only become more even though
they become a little less beloved
they've only become more fashion yeah
yeah you're right you're right but maybe
maybe and this is like why Kim didn't
like do a big thing about Balenciaga
like maybe this would be her punishment
for not standing by them because
remember we said like what does she have
to lose by dissing Balenciaga she
doesn't need the money but you said that
like it could be an industry thing where
it's like because really no one Anna
never said anything about it no nobody
wants to be known as like The
Whistleblower
and so Kim like speaking out like she's
what we know about her is like for as
long as she's been famous she's been
dying to get into the inner circle of
fashion and she's there now she's gonna
make some big stink and have everyone
think oh like oh she tattled on us but
she didn't even make a big stink she
just stopped working with them but maybe
that would be enough no I don't think
it's enough no enough for them to like
kick her out but she's now with Dolce
Gabbana she's still fashioned and they
usually have a table
Yeah question mark I don't know
anyways if she goes with them she'll
look amazing yeah those looks are much
nicer looking agreed than Balenciaga
like leggings
ugly yeah okay cool well that makes me a
little excited for oh and the theme is
so good it's Carl yeah oh and Kendall
was so close with Carl she'll be there
yeah it was a Carl girly let's just
let's chalk this up to you know game of
telephone yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah so
I'm actually shocking news Sammy
sweetheart oh my God into the Jersey
Shore after a decade-long Hiatus and
after saying she would never come back
to the show
over 10 years after she left the
original series Sammy sweetheart
giancola has reunited with her castmates
to film Jersey Shore family vacation MTV
announced Saturday the network revealed
the news via social media by sharing a
photo of the reality star sitting on a
chair with a boom mic and a camera in
frame seemingly filming a confessional
Sammy also confirmed the exciting
comeback by reposting the same pic to
her Instagram stories and Twitter fans
were quick to express their thoughts on
social media writing things like oh my
God stop this is right stop so it's been
over a decade since fans have seen her
on the show with her cast mates she had
said she wasn't coming back to the
reunion because she was like newly
married and wasn't going to go be around
her toxic ex Ronnie magro no and if you
watched Jersey Shore recently as an
adult and you saw what went down in
their relationship like you understand
we chalked it up as kids like oh they're
crazy watching it now as an adult like
you realize how abusive and
manipulative manipulative Ronnie was as
a boyfriend and like why anyone would
return to that now that they're happily
married like I have so much respect for
her not returning but I love this like
it feels like she's in a really good
place well what two things one Beyond
he's uh was a horrible boyfriend an
extremely toxic person like when you are
married you do not enter a situation and
a share house with your ex of
yeah that's insane so I really
appreciate her just like putting her
actual reality above reality television
because we talk about this all the time
how are you ever supposed to get over
someone when you are with them like if I
would never allow my spouse to go and
like do that I don't care that it's for
a TV show like this is our life yeah no
it's the way you just said it is perfect
like putting your own reality before
reality TV and like actually having
boundaries and not letting like money
influence that is something I have
enormous respect for but as somebody
who's like a huge fan of the show I'm
very excited to see her come back and I
feel like I'm glad she took time and
like she got married and maybe she's
feeling really settled and really secure
and like good enough to go and Ronnie's
not on the season he is taking a break
amid mental health issues and legal woes
uh he said after talking to the team at
MTV we have mutually agreed that I'll
step away from the show while I seek
medical treatment for my mental health
issues that I've ignored for too long my
number one goal is facing my struggles
head on because we've reported over the
years like he has these domestic oh my
God in like insane legal with that woman
he had a baby with like really insane
stuff so he's not on which is why she's
coming oh okay that makes a lot of sense
yeah sorry I've been like waiting to add
that detail oh sorry because it's your
main it's Jermaine it's Jermaine okay
that's great and uh you know what
Sammy's like such a cute little
influencer now she's like a little
Boutique like I feel like she's a really
nice happy like healthy like Balanced
Life so I'd love to hear from her and
see where she's at with all the girls
yeah I think it's gonna that's gonna be
a theme of the season is her kind of
making amends with the girls because I
think she kind of blew them off when
family vacation started they really want
her to come back and then Snooki said
like Sammy blocked her even maybe she
just like couldn't handle deal with it
all of it so I think represent but
honestly if they can get to a good place
with Angelina anyone can get to a good
place with anyone I mean how much do you
think MTV paid Sammy sweetheart like a
ton I hope so me too
because this is really exciting no this
is like major news and she's not even
like the best cast member no but it's
like
their family they're a family and that's
what the cast has said over the years
like it's it's not who said this um
Snooki she said she's a part of the show
I feel like it's not full unless all of
us are there no it's true they're a
family it's been incomplete I feel like
the
new show family vacation is great and
stuff but like it's definitely been
missing like and if they tried to fix it
with Angelina I'm like try a Shima
Angelina is not a part of the show no I
mean she is now and she definitely no
filled a part of the hole but there was
still more whole yeah and I think Ronnie
should really get off of TV for good
like he's he is such a toxic person he
is like he's more toxic now than he was
back then like he is so honestly
atrocious
and I'm so glad that she doesn't have to
be in the same house as him yeah well
she wouldn't have but I'm glad that we
can have her and not him right now me
too I love this like if you follow her
on social media like you know she's like
really cute she's like a really cute
life and I'm I'm excited to see what
she's been up to same
are you ready for our next story is this
number four number four is it the four
story that's brought to you Bob it's a
full story it's a four story bro that's
brought to you by droplet
did you know that 90 of your skin care
goes to waste because it gets wiped or
sweated off before fully absorbing into
your skin that's why we're so excited to
introduce you to this new product we've
been using the droplet because when we
heard the statistic we were shook that
is shook worthy it's shook worthy and
you know what it kind of makes sense
because like whenever I used to do my
skincare and just get into bed and like
it would literally rub off on my pillow
like it it's not that difficult to
understand and that's why I've been
loving using the droplet so their
award-winning handheld device transforms
your serums into high velocity micro
Mist that absorbs into the skin 20 times
deeper than topicals where the
ingredients can actually do some good so
the device also pairs with their droplet
mobile app to unleash the most powerful
deeply penetrating results and it lets
you personalize your skin care routine
with targeted treatment modes so here's
how it works choose the serum that best
meets your skin care needs and start
misting so for me my skincare needs are
always especially this time of year my
skin is really dry and like putting on a
bunch of serums and moisturizers then
going to bed
I understand now why the results weren't
so great because they really were not
absorbing into my skin so droplet is fun
and easy to use and it delivers powerful
treatments in under 60 seconds morning
and night right from the comfort of your
own home it feels like a Mist but it
offers an injectable
alternative without needles pain or
recovery time it's the ultimate
self-care experience from the comfort of
your home the device works like uh like
with formulation capsules kind of like
an espresso pod so you can use it to
infuse the treatments that are right for
you
not just in onto your skin but into your
skin so if you want to try it out for a
limited time listeners can get 50 off
your droplet device at droplet.io and
use code toast that's
d-r-o-p-l-e-t-t-e dot i o code toast
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
next story bumped to number four this
week scandival continues Tom Schwartz
was uh seen at the airport speaking to
TMZ commenting on Scandal and how he
spoken to Tom and that he there's a
profound sadness he said that Tom is a
piece of not in a way that it's
like he was actually scolding him he
said I haven't spoken to Tom today I
think you know they're very much close
aligned um he talked about how he was
very sad about the effect that it's
having on his business he's very sad
it's all they care about I know but like
I get it on a personal level but like
stop telling people that I know and then
he said well he said before that hit
about like he was so sad for Ariana then
he said I'm worried about my business
and I'm worried about Ariana
um Ariana meanwhile was at a friend's
wedding in Mexico this weekend looking
like she was having fun uh and on
Thursday night or Wednesday night
Vanderpump Rules was on last week and
Lisa Vanderpump was not Watch What
Happens Live have you had a chance to
watch I watched some of the clips and I
watched the new episode on the plane
last night of pump rules you don't
understand I actually am shocked at the
way the season is still giving even I
know we're so behind because listening
to everything that Raquel says and was
seeing everything that she does like
knowing what she's capable of and
knowing that like right around now I
need an official start I know but
according to the seven months like we're
in the affair I literally don't believe
that but what's interesting is Tom in
his statement said that he didn't tell
Ariana because he was worried about her
mental health which actually does
coincide with the loss of the dog and
how right after that would not be a good
time and then like you know time goes on
and on Lisa actually had a really good
theory as to why Tom and Raquel didn't
come forward she said that she thought
that they were trying to make it through
the reunion of this season have the
season be what it was then he would
break up with Ariana off camera and
start dating Raquel and by the time and
that would be crazy but they wouldn't be
airing and by the time the new season
started people would have had a chance
to get used to it yeah no that's a
really good call they were so close two
weeks away by the way anyone else like
sobbed during like the dog stuff I was
like literally not okay oh and no but it
was really sad and it was just even
sadder knowing like knowing what we know
knowing what we know and I can't even no
it was so sad
um and you're right like I do see that
like maybe he tried to tell her
right there but then her dog died so she
needed some time and like life just gets
away and like you try to tell someone
something so many times but like it's
just never the right time anyone else
have the eye theory that maybe Tom
Sandoval forgot to give the medication
that she had told him of course I
thought that that's like Cameron and um
yeah Court from real houses of Dallas
like at least they were like honest
about it though yeah no I could totally
see a world in which Tom Sandoval was
not listening did not he had to pick up
more medication and write it to the dog
no he was like half listening I need by
the way when Andy does like a call out
on Twitter and Facebook for questions
for the reunion somebody can you guys
all like ask him that like if we all ask
he can't ignore it it's a good question
it's a good question I will people
forget to ask it was my first thought
yeah it was but then I forgot about it
because I was just like sad for Ariana
and she didn't seem to think about it so
I literally forgot until right now yeah
but it's possible and then also that
whole Oliver Raquel thing was really
weird and so I don't know what I would
have been thinking about Raquel this
season if I didn't know what I already
know about her
um because she's acting crazy
like lala made it explicitly clear like
she was interested in all of her and so
and the Raquel just like sneaks her way
in so honestly watching this footage
like I'm actually not surprised knowing
what she did with Tom Sandoval because
she's kind of being like a
Jezebel a jezebel like a sleuth like
yeah no I would have chalked it if I
didn't know what I know I would have
watched this and chalked it all up to
Raquel being dumb and like not
understanding like social cues and but
not her literally being like Insidious
and just like this Jezebel of a Woman by
the way I like really I cannot watch
James's mom like I think she is like the
worst
yeah like I'll just had some bad moments
uh wishing Kristen Dodie to be Barren
remember that yeah like she has said
some of the most vile things and she's
literally been on the show four times I
can't watch her like she's horrendous
her saying I'm so glad you guys met
organically and then Ally in her
interview was like my friend dragged me
to a show I was I'm so confused about
ali because it actually seems like for
one of James's ladies she actually has
like some smarts yeah which is making me
think now that like maybe this is her
foray into television yeah you know
because like really all you have to be
is James's girlfriend and look you could
be on the cover of the star the New York
Post Yeah I I can't get a good read on
her either but like I do like her I like
her too because like I think she makes
sense and she gets mad at James
appropriately but she's also not dating
Raquel and like what James did to Raquel
is like she can't act like it happened
to her but she could still like you know
proceed with caution no I'm sorry Raquel
like trying to weigh whether or not she
should like go for Tom and being like
well Katie didn't come to my puppy party
I actually like I felt like serious like
shame and embarrassment just like having
to hear her say that yeah my puppy party
yeah
uh yeah and then next week where this
week looks crazy when they're in bed and
I guess Raquel is wasted and Lala says
like
um you know I would not trust drunk you
around my man and yeah Raquel said well
good thing you don't have a man to bring
around no honestly I don't know what we
would be thinking like watching this
season if we didn't know what we know
maybe we would just be thinking like
Raquel is spiraling yes oh for sure the
drinking is not helping her but a seven
month Affair isn't because you're drunk
all the time no no no but now knowing
what she's really like
none of this is really all that shocking
yeah knowing what she's capable of it is
shocking though because it's just like
she's so duplicitous and the fact that
she could sit at a table and I think
she's so shy she couldn't even make a
toast but she could sit at a table and
tell Katie's mother that she wants to
hook up with her daughter that she has a
crush on her daughter's ex-husband and
they're not even final divorce I'm like
you got a big brass set of balls yeah no
that's like delusion I loved
Katie's mom yeah like someone needed to
like bring the emotion into this and
just explain why what you're doing is
wrong but like that's not a shy
little girl
no who do you think is going to be on
watch Robin's Live Well I feel like I
feel like moving forward
whoever's gonna be on watch weapons live
after random rules like that's actually
more interesting than actually because
now we're finally getting real time
commentary of course Lisa's episode was
so interesting I think she was a little
wasted because she was being very loose
she was being crazy yeah I love that for
her
um I also felt like Andy dropped the
ball a little bit and Zach said the same
thing when we were watching that like it
just even though I think scandaval has
like you know pumped New Blood through
his veins like Lisa would say something
and he's just like constantly looking
through the cards
do you have all the questions in your
head this like this is the craziest
thing of all time the cards also that
last week's episode of Vanderpump Rules
was the highest raid episode in the last
two years which is not shocking to
anyone no I'm surprised it's not in the
last like 10 years no it's the craziest
thing yeah and by the way I had to buy
the episode on iTunes because I was
watching it on the plane yesterday and
Vanderpump Rules all the different
seasons are all over the iTunes charts
like number one two three four good good
also I feel like maybe Tom Schwartz will
be on this week because he was at the
airport coming I I want to say coming to
New York but also Jax was tweeting
remember oh yeah Jack said he's coming
yeah well actually no Schwartz was
interviewed by TMZ it could have been in
New York but probably was La it was
probably La I don't know but that was
the thought I had when I saw him in the
airport that like it's watched What
Happens Live oh I'm sorry what's up
inside I just saw the release their
schedule oh
I apologize give me one second
what night is Vanderpump Rules on
Wednesday
uh okay wait I hear I have the schedule
Wednesday is Katie Maloney and Danny
Pellegrino okay that's good yeah oh my
God Katie's gonna be so good yeah but we
need to hear from everyone honestly
watch Robin's lives ratings are about to
go through the roof Andy really needs to
like start caring again no and like put
the cards down have a conversation it's
gonna be okay he's mercuria yeah no he's
like addicted to the courage to the
cards yeah no I've always felt that way
it's like he doesn't really listen for
people's answers to respond because he's
looking for his next question whereas
the next question could come organically
if you just listen right and like you
can't listen to the answer if you're
looking for your next question but I
understand how with some people it's
like you know a like an actor or
something you have 20 minutes ask him
every question from all the fans that
and the fans are going to give you
questions from A to Z like I understand
fine but this is scandival
this is your like Super Bowl who has
more questions than Andy you're like the
Tom Brady get it together yeah
yeah
so I'm just living for absolutely
everything that's coming out of every
everyone Kristen was spotted filming yes
Kristen is filming but also Kristen it
doesn't have a Vanderpump Rules contract
so it's my understanding that a lot of
the castmates who have podcasts are
limited in what they can say
um but Kristen is not so Kristen
released an episode that everyone was
like eating up so if you want like some
real BTS check out Kristen's podcast
yeah
I heard a clip but I forgot what I heard
now but it was good yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
Story the news you've been waiting for
sure the 2023 Rosie winners are here oh
wow okay big day yep big day worse I
forget I forget that the razzies release
the same time as the Oscars they're so
funny they're so funny worst picture
blonde I agree and I didn't see it worst
actor Jared Leto morbius I didn't see it
but I feel like that's pretty accurate
worst actress they forgot to update the
winner but I'm using deductive reasoning
that it's Anna De armas blonde yeah
by the way total sidetracked but like
Elvis literally didn't win one Oscar uh
there were a few where I thought that
they might win like for um effects yeah
okay costume and set design because they
really recreated yeah but to recreate
something is different than creating
something out of nothing even though All
Quiet on the Western Front one and they
recreated World War one but like that's
different to create like you know a
battlefield it's kind of harder than
like a a set that already existed you're
just recreating it yeah look at stage in
Vegas like I just thought it was like
kind of crazy how like it was like such
a big movie but like when you really
boil it down like it was like low-key
not good like he was amazing and the
music like the movie itself was like
kind of bad I liked the movie a lot but
it wasn't an Oscars movie no there was
something a little too corny about it
yeah and I would say the corniness came
from Austin Butler yeah cheesy yeah
that I'm happy that he had his moment me
too
worst remake rip-off or sequel that's a
funny category Pinocchio wow even though
it won worst supporting actor Tom Hanks
Elvis oh my God thank you I finally feel
seen from the razzies thank you
worst screen couple
Tom Hanks and his latex Laden face and
ludicrous accent Elvis agreed thank you
razzy's finally doing something
important that is so funny how they um
just make up like couples that's not a
real yeah
no they're so funny so funny we're
screenplay blonde worst director Machine
Gun Kelly and mod sun in good morning I
don't even know what that is me neither
so the razzies have spoken the rosies
have spoken and you know what do they
lie no no lies we're told and that's
what's just so funny about like the
Oscars and just like this you know very
upper echelon filmmaking Community is
like they're giving out awards for best
when like the people like the razzies
like there are movies that are on both
lists yeah
gotta keep them humble but you know who
wasn't there Brendan Frazier no of
course not the razzies would never
everything everywhere all at once wasn't
there either right like I must have
liked performances yeah they liked it
um so that's the end of award season I
feel like we've been getting a lot of
news out of like those you know core
people Ariana Dubose Michelle yo Jamie
Lee Curtis Angela Bassett
um
Allison Butler Austin Butler we'll see
what next year's circuit brings and like
I feel like this year's circuit was like
not super A-list no and and that's what
I was saying like every year it's like
the same people who are nominated for
all the big award shows because they're
in the big movies and so we just see
them a million times and like I'm just
tired of this Bunch yeah this but
because I think this Bunch was very um
fabulous honestly yeah it had it had its
key Stars Michelle yo but like I don't
know overall it wasn't it wasn't like
the coolest crowd no it wasn't you know
it was not but
they there were some really good stories
in there Brendan Fraser key High Quan
like and that's better than some of the
fabulosity of you know like Jessica
Chastain winning again right even though
you know Jessica Chastain really never
disappoints
uh
she's been out recently I've heard she's
really good in George and Tammy which
I've been meaning to watch but like you
know how I felt about Tammy Faye oh I
loved Tammy Faye and then she won an
Oscar for it
oh I liked it I actually loved it and by
the way I love her yeah I know she's
your your twin she I like I love her and
I love and she always looks amazing I
thought she looked great last night why
was she wearing a mask in the audience
and then took it off like to talk like
as if oh I'm talking the virus can't get
me no I felt like if you're wearing a
mask you have coped oh my God I feel
like she like cats covered honestly fire
calls
um no I thought that was weird too only
like okay if you're gonna wear a mask
like and someone's talking to you like
you taking it off like literally defeats
the purpose of you putting it on so like
you're either being perfect you're
putting it on defeats the purpose like
if you're being performative or you
don't care which one is it uh
or you have covet in which you really
wanted to go no actually like now I'm
gonna need to rewind there's no reason
why she needs to be wearing a mask
unless she has coping and like so true
even still it was a cloth mask right
like sitting wearing a mask like bumper
to bumper with 50 people around you
is so dumb
because you're not helping anyone
no no and then she literally took it off
to talk like question mark
she took it off for the shared mic right
with balala and Colin Farrell yeah
so that's our show that's your Oscars
recap your pump rules recap your Libs in
recap
and we've got a great week coming up you
know we've got Tuesday we've got
Wednesday and then we also actually we
have Thursday and Friday what's so true
we do and not everybody show has that no
I would say I would argue none of them
do
very few all right so really really
we're Dale attorneys daddy daddy
thank you guys thank you so much for
listening to the toast to the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the
fastest stories that you need to know
everybody through Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching this on YouTube
please oh also John Travolta
um oh he came out and I think everyone
was like Adele does he I'm like ready
for him and he really he got choked up
um he he introduced it in memoriam that
was Lenny Kravitz and Olivia Newton-John
who it was um it was I think like it was
actually really sweet he got like really
choked up talking about Olivia Newton
John it's really sweet I heard Anne
Heche was left out oh you know what she
was
but then they did like for all the rest
of the people you know who aren't famous
enough to make the TV go to this website
it was kind of like really tacky
like either include everyone or don't
like don't send people to a website to
remember that's new yeah it was really
really like tacky
do you think she wasn't famous enough I
don't think so like people know her no
but like what would be the criteria for
getting on TV and then getting on the
website obviously like fame maybe Oscar
winner nah babe
Fame I Wanna Live Forever is that what
they say
I don't know
I know I know it goes like something
like yeah I Wanna Live do they say they
say Fame yeah cause the show's name is
Fame wait that's from Fame like I think
so now you're like making me question
everything forever
um okay I'm pretty yeah they say Fame
I'm gonna live forever I'm gonna learn
how to fly high I feel it coming
together
people will see me and cry remember
remember yeah cause you'll remember my
name cause I'm gonna be interested I'm
going to be famous Jackie's a musical
theater girl I know that was lame that
was like literally embarrassing
hello guys
thank you so much
podcast anywhere podcast
books all the places
five star review about our beautiful
setting and
secondly talented we are hope you have a
great day Jackie don't go into labor
love you bye